ich bin an ihre jugend erlaubt wieder
john und ich frage der geschwächte bäume
auf dem friedhof von bürgern treffe ich
einen den sein leben rund um den rv
geführt hat und der seit mehr als 30
jahren im herzen afrikas lebt im osten
des kongo hier wo sein vater begraben
liegt hier sind seine wurzeln
er ist aufgewachsen in einer streng
katholischen familie der vater munitions
arbeiter in altdorf
bald zog es ihn weg zuerst als skilehrer
nach arosa und im sommer hinaus in die
ganze welt
doch wo hat einer der so lange entlockt
rotter war seine heimat wo fühlte sich
wirklich zu hause davon handelt dieser
film
das mag ja wenn der vorige zieht hier
kennt jeder den kari und das halbe dorf
strömte zusammen als er in bürglen die
geschichte seines lebens vorstellte er
ist einer von ihnen aber einer der sich
weit entfernt hat von der enge der berg
in der schweiz erzählt aus seinem
abenteuer leben und er erinnert daran
wie er 1983 mit einem klapprigen vw-bus
in ein friedliches land tue und später
in einem brutalen tritt jetzt lebt er im
osten des kongo wo seit den 90er jahren
krieg herrscht
ingrid sauer studio 5 millionen toten
sind genannt sind in einem dicken buch
von über 500 seiten hat er
aufgeschrieben was sie was unglaubliches
widerfahren ist
in diesem leben wie aus einem
abenteuerroman
heute lebt carlos schule in bukavu am
chiemsee im kongo eine traumhaft schöne
gegend ein see umgeben von kranen und
naturparadiesen ein mildes klima ewiger
frühling eine gegend die ein wenig an
das tessin erinnert eine gegend die mal
einst die schweiz afrikas nannte hier
lebten früher viele ausländer
hier fand carlos die liebe seines lebens
christine skrabal und gründete mit ihr
eine familie bald kamen die beiden
kinder david und sarah zur welt alles
war gut bis 1994 die katastrophe begann
nach dem genozid in ruanda strömte mehr
als eine million flüchtlinge in den
kongo es kamen gewöhnliche leute die um
ihr leben gerannt waren
es kamen aber auch jene die für den
völkermord im nachbarland verantwortlich
waren
zwei jahre später begann ein bürgerkrieg
der weitere flüchtlingsströme
produzierte es folgten fast zwei
jahrzehnte von klein kriegen in denen es
vor allem um eines ging um bodenschätze
die opfer wie immer die einfachen leute
in diesen krieg im herzen der finsternis
2004 wurde die stadt bukavu von den
freischärlern des gen rassenkunde
überfallen
die die stadt verwüsteten und alles
blendeten was sie konnte das geschehen
wurde von den uno truppen sorgfältig
beobachtet von den uno truppen die für
mehr als eine milliarde dollar pro jahr
vor allem sich selber schützen
bis heute ist die bevölkerung von
250.000 auf beinahe eine million
angewachsen
hier herrscht das pure chaos
es gibt bei der abfallbeseitigung noch
abwasserentsorgung die arbeitslosigkeit
ist allgegenwärtig
die korruption ebenfalls
15 jahre ist es nun her seit ich carlos
zum ersten mal besucht habe ich erinnere
mich noch gut daran wie mich ein kleines
charterflugzeug von volume die in den
kongo brachte verstehen sie etwas von
flugzeugen hatte mich der pilot gefragt
nein sagte ich das ist auch besser so
antwortete der pilot flugzeugabstürze
sind hier so gewöhnlich wie andernorts
autounfälle
die reise führte mich zu unseren
nächsten verwandten den menschenaffen in
den wäldern des kongo und hier traf ich
carlos schule zum ersten mal
er fühlte mich durch den nationalpark
yahoo sieht jäger besuchte muga luca 1
200 kilogramm schweres corinna menschen
dass sich hier irgendwo versteckt hielt
und da ist er macht das immer von ganz
kurz sein ich zwei mal und dann machen
manchen sachen beobachtungen anzubieten
und wenn er ruhe aber letztlich
ungefährdet will alle klima wollen
arbeit erinnerte viele gefunden
absolut waren es immer man absolut
zufrieden
luca luca ist ein 13-jähriger silverback
ein silberrücken oberhaupt einer
siebenköpfigen gorilla familie
wir stören bei dem was sie zwölf stunden
an tage tun
fressen nämlich bis zu 30 kilogramm
blätter früchte unterbinden vertilgt ein
gorilla pro tag
doch der dschungel friede täuscht sogar
opa ist ein kriegsopfer sozusagen
ihm fehlt die rechte hand sie in einer
falle von wilderern stecken geblieben
wie durch ein wunder hat in kaluga das
alles überlebt
wenn verschiedene gorilla hier wo
allerhand ab aber das ist interessant
beobachtet zum beispiel dem broker es
unheimlich stark
selbst wenn elf beim sticken zur
wiederwahl screen das ist stark an eine
kräftig und herrschaftlich mit einer
hand ist mit einer und die andere
brauchte repariert zum irgendwie bambus
ablegen und so weiter
die schlimmsten fall sind die rieser
foul diese fallen rennt in das jahr über
50 wahnsinn dieser fall gefunden
was passiert also zehn sprachen dazu das
zu machen
und wenn sofern ich durch den referee
kunst daher klopfenden der rat zu holen
die zeichnung nahm die schau fall so der
hut denn der britische fahrer wie sie
einfach den stimmen es hat hier das
dauert sachen überlebt und malawis
stirbt er an infektionen und das hat
längere pausen kommen sagen auf jede
frau die diese unheimlich den weg
das große morden park kostete mehr als
der hälfte aller gorillas das leben in
nur vier jahren
sie wurden gejagt wegen ihres fleisches
oder als trophäen
es bestand die gefahr dass sie ganz und
gar ausgerottet werden
der grund für die krise im park ist klar
im osten des kongo herrscht seit 1996
ein brutaler krieg das ehemalige
touristenzentrum des parks gleicht
zeitweise einem heerlager viele der
menschen die hier kennenlernen sind auf
der flucht gejagt und terrorisiert von
soldaten aus mindestens sechs
verschiedenen fraktionen im kongo soll
sie knapp 20 jahren über fünf millionen
tote gegeben haben
aber eigentlich weiß das keiner so genau
im dschungelkrieg zählt niemand die
toten verletzten und vertriebenen
die parkverwaltung wurde zweimal
überfallen
die gebäude zerstört es wurde alles
geben wird was ein soldat wegtragen kann
das gesundheitszentrum dient der
us-truppen unterstand für verschiedene
rebellengruppen die berüchtigt sind für
raub mord und vergewaltigung
das muss man natürlich immer wieder ruft
gesehen alle anderen aus - kann und dass
ich als sehr positiv für den frieden
carlos war damals angestellter der
deutschen entwicklungshilfe der gtz
erließ gebäude bauen kümmerte sich um
die ausrüstung der parkwächter und die
fahrzeuge die deutschen experten die
früher hier waren mussten das land bei
kriegsausbruch hals über kopf verlassen
auf geheiß ihrer botschaft der schweizer
schule übernahm aus lokale angestellte
eine teil der projekte und rettete so
den park vor der totalen vernichtung
schüler lebt gefährlich
mir war etwas monika sich vor zwölf
jahren mit ihm bestimmt park für eine
woche von meinem besuch waren hier neun
landvermesser erschossen worden
von der gefürchteten guten soldaten
sechs gruppierungen kämpfen hier
gegeneinander ein durcheinander mit
kalaschnikows
wir können ist das eine
red
die zweifel zurück
sich wenigstens zu fragen
er kriegt
sonntags macht die familie schule
manchmal einen kleinen ausflug
allerdings nur in raub der stadt denn
aufs land wagte sich carlos damals mit
seinen kindern und seiner frau christin
nicht david und sarah damals elf und 13
jahre alt konnten über viele jahre nur
ein leben im kriegsgebiet die eltern
versuchten zwar das thema zuhause zu
vermeiden
doch war das nicht immer möglich der
krieg kam in der schlimmsten zeit bis
ins wohnzimmer der schule
das haus stand auf der frontlinie von
allen seiten wurde geschossen 12 100
millimeter maschinengewehr projektile
dass in sachsen ins kurz vor der kamera
ak probierte seite von hugo von buch und
sie möchte hier vorne mittig sie für
beide seiten und sind also einige hupen
und zu ist ja dass ich also ja ob sie ja
das taxi nimmt sie mit dem motto ich bin
da war die einfache beobachtet was
passiert und vermieter aber es ist so
vor so hoch geschossen wurde nicht
damals das hat also wahnsinnige lang
brauchte ich gar nicht mehr miteinander
ihn hat es beinahe erwischt es fehlten
ein paar zentimeter dann kam er zu uns
ins zimmer und da haben wir wirklich das
ende erwartet dass heute noch nach ja
die angst bleibt ich träume davon ich
habe albträume
das geht nicht vorbei wie war das für
die kinder
david der junge er war eigentlich das
stärkste von uns allen
er sagte hab keine angst mama aber sarah
hat gezittert wie ersten laut neben mir
ich versuchte so zu tun als hätte ich
keine angst aber mein ganzer körper
zittert unmöglich das zu verstecken und
so zum beispiel schutzgrad hinderung
also hintere setzt daher wo klinische
und ein offenes finde etappen ich war
heute nacht daher immer versucht
beobachtet lichtspur wo aus die skis
heger in der breite sind mit sexy und
schieße in den öffis und daher eine
oftmals usa haben wir dann auch alle
flugzeuge die von tieren mit einem
echten taktik gemacht
die kinder sollen möglichst normal
aufwachsen
trotz des krieges sie sind tapfer
spielen wie andere kinder auch und
versuchen den krieg zu vergessen
sarah die bis vor einem halben jahr nur
kriegsbilder zeichnete und aufsätze 7
gegen ihre freunde zu tode kamen
david der immer ein bisschen
nachdenklich wirkt
kristin schüler sie ist der grund warum
carlos auf die gorillas kam den sie
wuchs auf mit den tieren und den park
ihr vater arteriellen des klever ein
ehemaliger belgischer pflanze begann als
erster frei lebende gorillas an die
menschen zu gewöhnen
seine mission war es der menschheit zu
beweisen dass koreas keine gefährlichen
king kongs sind sondern friedliche
pflanzenfresser lebewesen ähnlich wie
wir nur entschieden friedliche des käfer
war ein mutiger mann und er setzte sich
den manchmal furchtbar wirkenden
attacken kasimir aus um zu beweisen wie
harmlos das alles war
sein kampf für den park kostete dies
greife das leben
er wurde 1989 vergiftet er ist 49 jahre
alt
schwiegersohn carlos setzt sein werk
fort zusammen mit pele paeley einen pick
mähen der shona drehendes greife den weg
zu den gorillas gezeigt hatte dabei sagt
carlos geht es nicht nur darum die tiere
zu schützen nein auch den menschen die
im und um den park wohnen soll es besser
gehen
mit verschiedenen programmen versuchen
schulen otz die lebensbedingungen der
bevölkerung zu verbessern schulmaterial
wird verteilt gleichzeitig dienen solche
anlässe dazu die idee des naturschutzes
zu verbreiten
pflanzt bäume pflanzt bäume
sie geben uns luft singen die kinder
also als mit magda tier war für mich ist
das absolut wichtigste vor allem und
viel effizienter als seit jahren staffel
die jetzt beschützer und ich verstand
wieder mit also für mich ist man absolut
wichtigste das heißt wenn man tiere
keine beschützer ist für die mannschaft
der zukunft wehrführer tourismus vögel
ökonomie und so weiter warum bleiben sie
hier warum gehen sie nicht weg in die
schweiz mit ihrem mann weil ich einen
mann habe der wahrscheinlich mehr
afrikaner ist als ich so komisch das
auch klingen wenn sie frei wählen
könnten würden sie weggehen
ehrlich gesagt ich weiß nicht recht was
ich sagen soll
es ist paradiesisch aber manchmal bin
ich nachdenke und sehe wie unsere kinder
aufwachsen unter bedingungen die
überhaupt nicht normal sind für sie und
wenn ich dann wählen könnte dann würde
ich wahrscheinlich in die schweiz gehen
haben sie oft angst um ihn ja ist es zu
riskant was er tut
ja ich finde es zu riskant aber ich
selber gehe er nicht in den park und
manchmal denke ich er ist ja nicht
verrückt der weiß was er tut und so
verteilte hinaus in den park auch über
straßen auf die sich sonst keiner traut
carlos schule wie wilhelm tell ausbügeln
und wie sein held wider willen
motivation ist frauen manchmal wissen
dass man es positiv machen innere
negative situation im moment das heißt
positiv für die nächste generation und
da hier ist immer in meinem tun und
jetzt klarheit wird sich entwickeln
irgendwie dass es muss ja mal irgendwie
ein hu war daher bevölkerung für den
regisseur sei hierfür der riss ist
profitieren und so gut zum beispiel vor
der bodenschätze oder euch vor der natur
ich meine da hier gibt es alles was geht
daher hier gibt's alles und manche
überhaupt nicht
heute zehn jahre später leben immer noch
gleich viele gorillas inklusive egapark
wie damals die tiere zumindest sind
vorläufig gerettet
ein kleiner erfolg der carlos und seinen
leuten ein wenig hoffnung lässt in
dieser ziemlich hoffnungslosen situation
das war vor zwölf jahren in der
zwischenzeit hat sich das leben von
carlos und christin komplett verändert
christin hat den kampf aufgenommen gegen
die systematischen vergewaltigungen in
den kriegsgebieten des kongo
sie leitet ein heim für hoffer dieses
sexuellen terrors mehr darüber im
zweiten teil dieser reportage